the knee is in Georgia
hi Anthony welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey that's right certainly how can
I help
well 20 years old and a full-time
college student I also do work full-time
I make about thirty thousand a year and
right now I rent an apartment with the
roommates and pay about four hundred and
eighty that's including utilities and
rest and my question was you know would
it be smart to maybe get a jumpstart and
possibly buy the house I have no debt
whatsoever
and my school is still paid for I'm
until I graduate and right now I'm just
kind of sitting on money went what arm
when will you graduate it will be many
of 2021 and during my junior year what
are you studying I'll finance excellent
cool and where are you graduating from
what school you the University of North
Georgia so you're in what city okay this
is Dahlonega Dahlonega yeah okay
beautiful - little town okay yeah I
didn't realize the University of North
Georgia was there okay cool and so when
you graduate the likelihood of you
working in your finance degree in
Dahlonega Georgia is almost zero yes sir
the likelihood of you moving to take
full advantage of that career is very
high what would be your plan then
are you planning to move is that am I on
track there more towards things or an
area because right now he actually was
in games with me partner yeah I just can
go on and go but um what do you think
you'll stay in Gainesville and work out
of there when you graduate is that your
plan it was okay because there's usually
I mean when someone graduate from
college is a high likelihood they
a high likelihood time of changing
cities as any time in your life really
because you typically are going to take
your first job in your career field and
it's not unusual for you to choose to
move to a different city during that
time okay which means that buying a home
would have been a mistake
so it would be okay to buy if you want
to now I wouldn't because two things or
two things happen between now and twenty
five years old a high percentage of the
time not always but a high enough
percentage of the time you get married
graduate from school and move those are
three things and all of those things
would affect the house that you own so I
probably wouldn't I all I was in the
real estate business when I was in
college had my real estate license
selling and I lived in a town just south
of Knoxville called Maryville Tennessee
not that far from where you are in
Dahlonega and because the other side of
the mountain range there's all and I
found a little house that was back in
those days very inexpensive nowadays it
would be so inexpensive you wouldn't
believe the number if I told you but I
almost bought a house when I was 20
years old in Maryville Tennessee
actually Alcoa Tennessee is where the
house was a little joining town and
eighteen months later I graduated from
school and got married and moved to
Nashville owning that house would have
been a huge mistake okay and I couldn't
see any of that when I was 20 by the
time I was 22 all the other things had
happened and so that it's just a not
saying that's exactly what's going to
happen to you just because it happened
to me that's not my point but the point
is is that you are at a stage of life
where transition is is a way of life and
so it's a it's a good reason to not buy
right now but if you feel very very very
sure you're not gonna leave Gainesville
in the next five to ten years then you
know you want to go ahead and buy you
can your income is going to change and
so you're gonna end up moving up in a
house later just because your income
changes because I hope
you make more than you make now after
you get this degree so you know that's
another thing to look at there's just a
lot of transition in your life a lot of
reasons you're renting when you've got
that much transition going on is not
wasted money it's buying patience it's
giving you patience is what it's doing
patience to wait and do something more
solid as permanent as the purchase of a
home is and so forth so that that's just
my speech you can do either one I'm not
mad at you pay Kay you know you put a
big down payment you stay out of debt
you put on a 15-year fixed with the
payments no more than four with your
take-home pay the guidelines we always
use you'll be fine and you can even sell
that house later probably Gainesville is
a wonderful town should have an active
enough real estate market that you're
not gonna get stuck in it